foreign
[Music]
this
is what I dream of
sometimes it feels like I'm still there
[Music]
one amongst hundreds of others
like me
to travel far to be here
is without a name
thank you
we would watch the moon rain the water
darkened
then
celebrations would begin
all of us together on the reef
our home came alive
remember that day
I remember him
but that
was a long time ago
let me tell you my story
I am a square tail grouper
[Music]
and this
is where it all began
shallow Blue Waters
I was a baby then
just another small spotted fish amongst
so many others
these branches were safe for young fish
like me
many of us lived here together
it was crowded but there was space for
everyone
it was a busy place
pretty buddies seem to be going
somewhere all the time
well not everybody
some of us found time for a nap
I learned so much just by watching
how to swim so that no one saw you
best places to keep a lookout on the
reef
when to stick together
stay close
everyone around you
my time in the lagoon taught me
something about everyone
and about the reef itself
chime danced on it by the day
[Music]
and the night
the Delight of the corals
summarizing
most days I spent swimming around
looking for food
one day
I heard a strange sound
a shadow went past above me
I followed to see what it was
[Music]
I reached a place I had never been
before
what was this
where was I
[Music]
these colors were new
the shapes odd
[Music]
I wondered about the shadows and if they
would return
something told me to leave
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
back in the lagoon
restlessness began to take hold of me
one morning chasing silverfish
I swam away from The Reef
I swam further than I had ever been
before
going
[Music]
curious
foreign
the light changed
this was a new place
it made me feel
all
everything was bigger here more open
at first I was scared
they were big Hunters here bigger than
me
that was so much more to learn
but I knew
this
is where I was meant to be
I like home
a few nights later
I woke up to see a few others like me
swimming quickly Over The Reef said
where are they going
I followed behind them
they weren't alone
by the time I got up I realized there
was something going on
and there
as far as I could see
fish swam around each other in huge
numbers
thing like this before
usually I saw two or three others like
me in a day
but today there were a thousand
the water vibrated with them
where are they all come from
what was happening here
[Music]
I waited and watched for a long time
that day
[Music]
saw him
I thought he looked my way but there are
too many others between us
she was strong and confident
he swam with the magic of the Open Sea
he looked so free
he didn't swim with the hundreds of
others nearby
maybe he was new here too
I watched him for a while
it's like that
he was gone
in time I learned all about the
celebration
happened for a few months every year
when the moon was only a sliver in the
sky
others like me swam for a long time to
come here
that was something special about this
Reef
everyone claimed a batch for themselves
during this time they were guarded
aggressively
came too close and there would be a
fight
it's jostled with each other and some
got hurt
they flashed different colors to warn
each other
Brown when chased white when showing
their strength
when they locked chores
he knew it was serious
do you see those scars
sometimes the fighting was bad and
didn't end well
[Music]
and they did all this for us
how they chased us around
when they saw us
they left their territories and danced
all around us
this was everyone's favorite move
a little shimmy to the left
a little shimmy to the right
and he got her
we danced with them too
sometimes hidden from View
it was a much awaited Gathering
and as luck would have it
I did see him again
after many moons had risen and said
[Music]
he did not perch on the reef slope like
a lot of others
there they had to fight hard to keep
their space
but he was not like them
he was different
I felt like he was waiting for me
was he looking my way
[Music]
one day I gathered up all my courage and
swam up to him
[Music]
and since then we found each other here
every time
spent many days exploring together
our home was full of things to do
this favorite spot to get his teeth
and some days we even joined the others
on their hunt
we were happy together
but it wasn't always easy here
sometimes the reef is stormy and rough
and it was hard to see in the murky
water
on one of those days that
I saw the shadow again
it went past above me
[Music]
scared everyone
this time it's
[Music]
put things in the water that
shined and sparkled
something didn't feel right
[Music]
I saw him swim towards it but I was so
far away
it all happened so fast
[Music]
I I tried to swim as fast as I could
I watched as he got pulled up
[Music]
and then
just like that
he was gone
the Shadows they took many of us that
day
one after another
and then they left
I followed to see where they were taking
them
foreign
ago
things here look so different now
the water was nothing like it used to be
earlier
it had been quiet
now there were loud sounds coming from
close by
surrounded me
then
[Music]
I remembered this place like it was
yesterday
I swam for a long time that day
[Music]
the place where I had grown up
had forever changed
the corals were gone
should I leave this place
but my body took me back to the only
place I knew
my home where I belong
s have risen and said since that day
but I keep going back to the place where
I first saw him
[Music]
Shadows come
the celebrations
are a memory
[Music]
there aren't many of us left here
but feasty
[Music]
I dream about that day
I dream about him
foreign
[Music]